over half of the world lives under an
authoritarian regime many are ruled by
dictators whose silence critics look up
opponents and torture dissidents one man
has made a career out of bringing down
dictators bringing down a dictator may
not sound like an easy task but it's
doable me and my friends succeeded
against the bad guy named Slobodan
Milosevic's back there in 90s these are
my talking points
you start this journey by envisioning
your future how the things would be
different if our movement wins the
nonviolent humans become massive when
the things become personals who really
need to figure out what do people need
and what will mobilize them in order to
get this change sometimes that means
travelling with a very strange bunch of
people look at the poem back there in
80's the Solidarity movement was that
truly consisting over three very
different groups urban intelligentsia
Roman Catholic Church and blue-collar
workers not really the guys you would
expect to see around the table in the
pub but sometimes you need to build a
very very strange and unlikely
coalition's but this is how you win what
connects the successful movements is
something we call the holy trinity of
success it's unity because you need a
various people it's planning because
there are only two types of nonviolent
struggle there it'll spontaneous or
successful there is no such thing as
continuous and successful and of course
nonviolent discipline because this is
what gives you the moral leverage to
succeed one of the things which is
really important for the movement is
actually people it's people power
movement so the more people you have the
more skillful these people are the
bigger the impact you can achieve at one
point Serbian awkward resistance
movement at 70,000 members if you put
70,000 members in activity for two hours
a day you out match Google of course you
will need some money where to find this
money try looking at your phone book try
looking at your friends and supporters
they always say first you find money
with friends and fools it's very similar
with nonviolent movement but when it
comes to government beware foreign
governments don't have friends own
interests
at the moment your movement starts being
successful your opponent is going to
take his little dick tear Kill Bill
playbook and start picking labels to use
the propaganda to dismantle your effort
it will start by you being a seduced
citizen then it will continue with you
being non patriotic probably a traitor
foreign mercenary junkie it may even end
putting you on a terror list how many
polar bears have you saved this morning
by clicking like on a Facebook page not
really
the bells and changes are happening in
the real world not in a virtual world so
the ideal combination of offline and
online world is what you want to look at
when you're using social media
in order to really win in your movement
you need to have a strategy for the day
after victory and when you look at the
Egypt for example you had 19 days
millions of people in the street
bringing down the very harsh opening and
then the people proclaim the game over
and pull back and leave a transition to
the military and Muslim Brotherhood well
look what they get they get a society
which looks worse there is a big danger
in taking democracy for granted
democracy is like love you need to make
it every day